Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In this series, we often talk about computer
animation and physical simulations, and these
episodes are typically about one or the other.
You see, it is possible to teach a simulated
AI agent to lift weights and jump really high
using physical simulations to make sure that
the movements and forces are accurate.
The simulation side is always looking for
correctness.
However, let’s not forget that things also
have to look good.
Animation studios are paying a fortune to
record motion capture data from real humans
and sometimes even dogs to make sure that
these movements are visually appealing.
So, is it possible to create something that
reacts to our commands with the controller,
looks good, and also adheres to physics?
Well, have a look!
This work was developed at Ubisoft La Forge.
It responds to our input via the controller
and the output animations are fluid and natural.
Since it relies on a technique called deep
reinforcement learning, it requires training.
You see that early on, the blue agent is trying
to imitate the white character, and it is
not doing well at all.
It basically looks like me when going to bed
after reading papers all night.
The white agent’s movement is not physically
simulated and was built using a motion database
with only 10 minutes of animation data.
This is the one that is in the “looks good”
category.
Or, it would look really good if it wasn’t
pacing around like a drunkard, so the question
naturally arises, who in their right minds
would control a character like this?
Well, of course, no one!
This sequence was generated by an artificial,
worst-case player which is a nightmare situation
for any AI to reproduce.
Early on, it indeed is a nightmare.
However…after 30 hours of training, the
blue agent learned to reproduce the motion
of the white character, while being physically
simulated.
So, what is the advantage of that?
Well, for instance, it can interact with the
scene better, and is robust against perturbations.
This means that it can rapidly recover from
undesirable positions.
This can be validated via something that the
paper calls impact testing.
Are you thinking what I am thinking?
I hope so, because I am thinking about throwing
blocks at this virtual agent, one of our favorite
pastimes at Two Minute Papers, and it will
be able to handle them.
Whoops!
Well, most of them anyway.
It also reacts to a change in direction much
quicker than previous agents.
If all that was not amazing enough, the whole
control system is very light, and takes only
a few microseconds, most of which is spent
by not even the control part, but the physics
simulation.
So, with the power of computer graphics and
machine learning research, animation and physics
can now be combined beautifully, it does not
limit controller responsiveness, looks very
realistic, and it is very likely that we’ll
see this technique in action in future Ubisoft
games.
Outstanding.
This video was supported by you on Patreon.
If you wish to watch these videos in early
access, or get your name immortalized in the
video description, make sure to go to Patreon.com/TwoMinutePapers
and pick up one of those cool perks, or, we
are also test driving the early access program
here on YouTube, just go ahead and click the
join button, or use the link in the description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!